say was Prince George's first day of
school take a look at that but sadly it
started without mom Kate who continues
to battle severe morning sickness so it
was dad to the rescue
clutching his father's hand a little
George was just too adorable walking
into Thomas's Battersea School in South
London William dutifully carried his son
school-issued bag and they were greeted
by the head of the lower school royal
watchers saying leaving multiple
versions of this uniform gets pricey
George's Navy genic pullovers around $32
matching bermuda shorts are just over
$30 their winter socks are just over $9
and George's black shoes are almost $45
everything that each student needs air
tickles around five hundred dollars
tuition starts at more than $23,000 a
year and George's attendance marks a
break with royal tradition previous
generations of Royals have generally
gone to single-sex schools but at least
at Thomas's back to see it doesn't mean
in a couple of years Charlotte can
follow in her big brother's footsteps
pupils are taught kindness proper
etiquette and the importance of human
rights and that should appeal to William
who fought for those less fortunate
George can expect to have fun too there
are over two dozen after-school clubs
with everything you can think of perhaps
George might take up golf like his dad
but one activity is required compulsory
for all boys and girls up to the age of
7 is Ballad class there are several
ballet shows that take place throughout
the year of course Princess Diana
George's grandmother was a huge ballet
fan and so this is probably something
that she'd very much enjoyed is it scary
that I remember Williams first day and
now look at George he's growing up